I find it you know so astonishing I get
critics even from the right that are
saying you know
um we think critical race theory is
horrible um we think Dei is antithetical
to the Constitution
but we're really concerned that rufo is
getting rid of them within public
institutions it's like
what are you people for I mean what what
how do you go from that just specific
conclusion sorry to interrupt I just a
steel man that argument and I have seen
that argument made please their argument
I think is they're uncomfortable with
using the power of government to do
those things that is their concern
totally but but that is like the most
absurd concern possible because they're
uncomfortable with using the power of
the government to regulate the
government these are government schools
these are government institutions and so
the only per the only people who can
regulate them are the are government you
know agents essentially and so what my
argument is is if you say that
legislators
channeling the the the sentiments and
desires of their voters
are not allowed to regulate public
institutions what you're saying is that
the supreme power in our country is not
the people it's not the legislators who
represent them but the permanent
bureaucracies and the permanent
bureaucrats that administer our
institutions and so it is fundamentally
an anti-democratic argument that they're
making they're saying the people have no
right to regulate their government
um that is completely backwards to to
the to the to the vision of the American
founding where the people people were
the ultimate Arbiter and the government
only secured only existed to secure the
rights of the people
um now now we're getting into a kind of
tyrannical uh model
ultimately what I think is important for
people to realize is that there's a
distinction between ideology and
politics and my contention that I've
Advanced and and has gotten a lot of
pushback
um but but I think is is ultimately
still true is that
our universities have been overly
ideologized but insufficiently
politicized and so what that means is
that we have you know critical theory
post-modern post-modernism gender
ideology driving intellectual life in
the Departments but we have this fiction
that universities are neutral spaces
that should not be governed by anyone
and that certainly shouldn't be intruded
upon by legislators and taxpayers and
voters who fund them Charter them and
pay for them what I'm saying is that
it's time for public universities to be
governed in the best interest of the
public and to be governed specifically
by the legislators who are elected by
voters uh to to fund oversee and
administer these institutions academics
want to be free to push their ideology
at all times but they also want to be
free of democratic oversight I hope that
to reverse that I hope that the opposite
becomes true over time
Chris and let's focus on the Ivy Leagues
the the harvards you know the Columbians
Etc these are private institutions
correct me if I'm wrong because I'm I'm
not particularly okay okay
so what do we do with a private
Institution
because that's not governmental so what
do we do with them
well this is actually a fun question and
I'm glad you asked because I've been
working with some other Scholars and
policy analysts on exactly this question
and there's a couple things we can do I
mean uh you know a private universities
are subsidized to the gills by the
federal government through student loans
and student loan guarantees and so I
think that you could reform student
loans and make universities liable in
part for student loan defaults so if a
student racks up 25 you know 250 000 in
student loans getting a gender studies
degree from you know private university
a uh and then can pay it back well why
isn't the university on the hook to
repay that say half of that loan so
create some Financial incentives for
them to be more more competitive and
more judicious in how they they run
their their programs
second what you can do and what I'm
recommending uh the next president of
the United States to do uh you know if
it's a republican
um is is to launch a Department of
Justice and Department of Education
investigation into all of the ivy league
universities uh to investigate them for
uh illegal and unconstitutional uh
racial discrimination in hiring and
Admissions and so what we would do is
essentially take what what the the
lawyers did with the Harvard lawsuit
which established that that Harvard's
admissions policies was unconstitutional
um
we're unconstitutional and then expanded
to all of the prestige universities
using the power of federal investigation
um to to procure documents to put you
know a few hundred lawyers on the case
uh and and in a sense to to to embarrass
to expose to punish and then to take
corrective legal action against
universities who are violating the
Constitution I think that would make
waves I think that would make huge
changes in behavior and I also think
that Federal uh Federal funding for
these universities they get billions of
dollars private universities get
billions of dollars in in Grants and in
programmatic funding and other kind of
uh federal financial schemes
why don't we tie that funding to
principles of open speech and debate
principles of Civic discourse principles
of non-discrimination
um and and in a sense say
um if you don't fulfill the basic
mission of the University being a home
for open discourse having a standard of
civil debate you no longer qualify for
federal funds uh this is how it works
and almost every other domain of life if
you do not follow the basic rules you do
not qualify for special benefits and so
I think there's a lot that can be done
to to tame these private universities
and one thing I've learned in particular
fighting in Academia
academics are not very you know they're
not economically productive right
they're they're not uh you know creating
uh you know iPhones or whatever
um what they have what they trade on is
prestige um and that's really their
fault they always put their full the you
know the the famous Jacob yorovski
professor of whatever at Yale University
uh the the famous line from Jason
Stanley and so what I've learned by by
kind of you laugh at that it's kind of
funny but but actually it signal signals
a great vulnerability if you can um Can
attack The Prestige and attack the
reputation uh and and and and and and
and undermine the The Prestige
reputation of individual academics but
academic institutions as a whole
um that is a very powerful method for
getting change
thank you
foreign